-Guys, it's time for "Good Name,
Bad Name, Great Name."
Here we go.
-♪ Good names, bad names,
great names, yes ♪
-First up, we have --
I love that theme.
-♪ Good names, bad names,
great names, yes ♪
-Thank you very much.
First, we have
"Only Murders In The Building."
Well, that's a good name
for a show on Hulu.
It's a bad name
for a Zillow listing.
Great name for Red Lobster.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next, there is "Paper Source."
Well, that's a good name for
a store that sells stationery.
Bad name for a forest.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-♪ Good name, bad name,
great names, yes ♪
-I didn't get to the punch line
yet.
-Well, you got to get it.
Come on.
Paper shortage.
-I know.
Great name
for a CVS receipt printer.
You know what I'm saying?
That's -- [ Stammers ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
All I bought was a pack of gum!
-I don't have a card.
-I told them that.
-Gosh, I really don't have one.
-'Cause I didn't want
to wait a half hour.
-Believe me.
I wouldn't lie to you.
After that, we have
"Let There Be Carnage."
-Ooh.
-That's a good name
for a "Venom" sequel.
A bad name for a zoo.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name for TJ Maxx.
You know, it's just like
[Shouts indistinctly]
"Give me that!"
After that,
we have Machine Gun Kelly.
Well, that's a good name
for a rapper.
It's a bad name
for a new Barbie doll.
[ Laughter ]
-Machine Gun Kelly, yeah.
-It's a great name
for Kelly Clarkson's
Call of Duty screen name.
There you go. See?
[ Applause ]
After that, we have
"The Legend of the Ten Rings."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, that is a good name
for a Marvel movie.
It's a bad name
for your bathtub.
It's a great name
for Tom Brady's autobiography.
There you have it. Wow.
Let's see, let's see.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next up, there's "Cry Macho."
That's a good name
for a Clint Eastwood movie.
Bad name for a WWE wrestler.
A great name
for ghost pepper hot sauce.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It's so good.
I would like another hot wing,
please."
[ Laughter ]
Next, there is "Back 4 Blood."
That's a good name
for a video game.
It's a bad name
for the Red Cross.
[ Groaning, laughter ]
-What?
Wow. Lot of --
-It's a great name
for a vampire boy band.
There you go, yeah. Back --
Back 4 --
-♪ Back for blood ♪
♪ Fangs ♪
-♪ Back 4 blood ♪
-♪ Somewhere in the night ♪
-Finally, we have
"Truth Be Told."
Well, that's a good name
for an Apple TV+ show.
Bad name for bathroom scales.
It's a great name for tequila!
There you have it! That's "Good
Name, Bad Name, Great Name."